Hi. My name is Frank Schulenburg and I'm the Wikimedia Foundation's
Head of Public Outreach. The Wikimedia Foundation is the organization
behind Wikipedia, the encyclopedia that everybody can edit.
So I'm here today to tell you more about Wikipedia and
why you as a science student should help Wikipedia to get better.
Let me start with a story about what impact Wikipedia can have.
This is the story of Judy. And Judy is the mother of a 20 year old daughter
from Florida and Judy's daughter was diagnosed with cancer
at the age of 2. So 18 years ago, and at that time, Judy spent hours
in medical libraries to get more information about the specific type
of cancer that her daughter had. And 18 years ago, I mean,
she could find little information
about that specific type of cancer. She couldn't understand
the medical terms she was reading. However, her daughter survived.
And then, 12 years later, Judy's daughter was diagnosed with
a different kind of cancer and this time Judy used the internet
and Wikipedia. She was armed with knowledge about the disease,
its causes, and possible treatments. And she sent us an email last year
when we were in the middle of our yearly fundraiser, and Judy said
"Wikipedia and the internet has helped me to gain a sense of control
over the uncontrollable." I think this is a really nice story to see
how Wikipedia impacts the lives of people. So let me tell you more
about Wikipedia, let me give you some numbers, and let me tell you
more about who's behind Wikipedia, who writes it. Let's start with
the numbers. Wikipedia right now has 18 million articles in more
than 260 languages. And what I find really impressive is that Wikipedia
worldwide, all of these language versions, get more than
400 million unique visitors per month. And all the content of Wikipedia
is written by volunteers. People like you and me. There are more
than 100,000 of volunteers who write Wikipedia articles, and they
don't get paid. They just do it because they like to learn
and they like to teach others and they like to share their knowledge
with others. And they all believe in the same vision, that vision statement
of the Wikimedia foundation, that is, we believe that it's good to create
a world where every single human being on this planet has access
to the sum of all knowledge. And now, back to the topic. So I said
I want to give you some reasons why you as science students
should help Wikipedia to get better. And I have three reasons.
First of all, if you write Wikipedia articles, you will learn a lot.
You will learn to translate your special knowledge to a general audience.
To an audience of people like Judy, who needs information and
who needs information that is written in an easy to understand language.
So you will also learn to write better. You will improve your writing skills,
because you will interact with the community of Wikipedia editors
and the readers, and you will get feedback, and people will tell you
"Hey, there is something that I didn't understand, and maybe you
can write it in a different way." So that feedback is really good.
And then also what you will learn is, you will improve
your digital media literacy skills, because when you write
Wikipedia articles, you will learn a lot about Wikipedia's culture and
you will learn a lot about what makes a good article and why are some
articles not as good as other articles, so you will learn a lot about
how the quality of Wikipedia, how Wikipedia gets created and that's
one of the big learnings. So the second reason why I think you as a
science student should help Wikipedia to get better is, you can give
something back. So I guess that most of you use Wikipedia
at least once a week. And let me tell you about me, I use
Wikipedia every day and five years ago I decided I wanted to give
something back to Wikipedia. So I studied history and five years ago
I started to improve history articles on Wikipedia, and it gives me
a good feeling because I'm taking information from Wikipedia every day.
I learn a lot, I enjoy reading Wikipedia articles, so I give something back.
So the third reason why I think you as a science student should help
Wikipedia to get better is that huge audience that Wikipedia has.
Imagine the cancer article on the English Wikipedia gets
more than 200,000 views per month. Isn't that amazing?
So many views? I remember when I wrote articles for scientific journals,
maybe I got 20 readers or so. But on Wikipedia, my articles reach
much more people, and this is a great thing. So imagine you would
help to make the cancer article better, and you would get
more than 200,000 views per month. Wouldn't that be great?
So here's the three reasons again, you will learn a lot,
you can give something back to Wikipedia, and you will write
for a huge audience. And now there are many ways you can help Wikipedia
to get better. You can just take a look at an article and look at
the language, and maybe you want to copy-edit it. It's very easy.
You just click on the edit button, and you can start copy-editing
and then you click save and everything is done and you've helped
Wikipedia to get better. You can also fact check Wikipedia articles,
existing Wikipedia articles, or you can upload pictures or you can even start
a new Wikipedia article, and it's really easy. Go to Wikipedia,
click on the edit button and then start editing. And you can help
people like Judy to find the information that they need.
Thank you very much.